hey guys dr berg here i have a question
can't sleep do this number one
always sleep on your right side why
because the heart is on the left side
and the liver is on the right side
and so many people have either a fatty
liver
or a congested liver and when you sleep
on your left side the way the liver can
compress
on the heart it's much better if the
heart is sitting on top of the liver
sleeping on your right side and you'll
find that your breathing will be better
your sleep will be better if you sleep
on the right side okay that's number one
number two slow your breathing down so
what you want to do is you want to focus
on your breathing
here's here's what happens when your
adrenals are overstressed the breathing
is kind of like this
i'm exaggerating but the exhalation is
shorter than inhalation
so what you want to do is you want to
sink your breathing with an equal amount
of
inhalation and exhalation about four to
five seconds
each okay so it's kind of like you're
gonna slowly count to
four or five as you're breathing in like
one two three four
one two three four as you're breathing
out
so you're slowly breathing in and slowly
breathing out
as you're trying to sleep i find that
really helps your sleep okay
so because you because some people are
like often they catch themselves
like holding their breath when they're
trying to sleep this is a really good
thing to focus on as you
drift off into a sleep okay number three
bed by 10
30 at least maybe a little bit earlier
because here's the problem
there's a circadian rhythm that occurs
and when you go to bed past
10 30 let's say 11 30 or 12 especially
you missed the make break point in other
words you may have to wait
up to an hour to even 90 minutes before
you catch the next
wave because these hormones go in cycles
up and down so if you're if you missed
out
on that circadian wave all of a sudden
you can't sleep you maybe
already know that like you might get
tired around 9 30 and like man if i just
went to bed now i could just sleep
and then all of a sudden you wake up
that's what i'm talking about
so you want to get to bed by 10 30
because the optimum time of that
circadian wave
is about 10 45 11 o'clock that's when
your your body drifts off into a sleep
so i consistently
go to bed at that time and i can drift
off very fast but if i go to bed
like 12 i'll be laying there for an hour
okay
so that's one thing number four your
pulse rate
if you ever go to bed and you hear your
pulse rate on the pill like boom
boom boom boom what that means is that
you're deficient in potassium
if you're deficient in potassium your
heart will beat
louder and harder in a higher pulse rate
normal pulse rate
72 but you want it kind of like 65 60.
so if it's too high what you need to do
is you need to start eating more
vegetables because you don't have enough
potassium in your body it's a good
indicator
of low potassium you need to increase
that and you'll drift off
but really what causes a potassium
deficiency
is like really two things one is stress
for many years
because stress will deplete your
potassium the adrenal or number two
sugar if you eat too much sugar it will
definitely deplete your potassium
and your pulse rate will go higher and
higher and higher okay
last one massage tool there's a massage
tool that i use before i go to bed it's
a tool that i develop for my own body
and i actually have you linked down
there of how to use it
and you can get some ideas but this i do
my neck points before i go to bed
i do my mid-back points and i do my
adrenal points every night before i go
to bed
it's a real simple no-brainer i take
this on vacations everywhere i go
because it just helps me get to bed fast
there are certain acupressure points
that you do on your neck and the
adrenals
that will just turn things off and you
will sleep a lot better
so it helps pull stress out but it's a
kind of a do-it-yourself model and
depending on how big you are you can use
the real small one medium or large okay
so
that's a great tool to pull stress out
to help you
um if you just can't sleep all right so
these are some tips
i will see you in the next video